il fallait tout prévoir qu'ils soient
étanches à l'eau qu'ils soient étanches
à l'humidité à l'air salin c'est un gros
défi parce que c'est un appareil de
précision de qui est calibrée en même
temps pour qu'ils résistent à
l'utilisation intensive une utilisation
intensive sur le terrain que ça me
prenait d un appareil qui était blanc
l'intérieur donc pour limiter pourquoi
est obligé de peinture et ou de peindre
ou de d'ajouter long l'habillage
extérieur alors on a développé on a
développé une résine blanche
complètement étanche avec des propriétés
uv juste la résine s'apprête peut-être 6
mois de développement donc c'est avec
cet appareil l'aune de deux de résine
différents encore là ça a été un beau
défi tout un défi parce que les
résidents des des retraits des chewing
âge différent donc fallu adapter un peu
nos design pour que l'appareil en fait
le couvercle s'adapter parfaitement aux
sûr puisque s'asseoir en fait
parfaitement sur le bac est en fait sur
le contenant parce que on pouvait pas il
faut il n'y a aucune lumière qui peut
qui peut il faut qu'il soit complètement
étanche à la lumière en même temps fou
qui soit aussi facile à insérer puis qui
bouge pas parce que si un moindrement un
mouvement ou qui n'est pas inséré
correctement ça va complètement changer
ça peut venir de venir diminuer la
précision de l'appareil toute
l'électronique est fait ici à québec
et puis les moules et puis l'injection
aussi de la résine
on a un partenaire avec nous dans la
bosse alors puis l'assemblage final est
tout fait ici en laboratoire